- that movie was amazing
oh good have lasers explosions that
badass training months - imagine if your
life was like what do you mean okay tape
working out for example right I've been
busting my ass in the gym for three
years and I'm still the guy who has to
play Santa at the office Christmas party
in the movies I cannot get the beer
belly in for three minutes and look like
a badass dude like my girlfriend's a
scientist and she's seriously bored at
work all the time this is impossible
if she was in the movies she'd go to
some mysterious island with an eccentric
billionaire and have like a dino posse
following her around all the time okay
what you saying I quit my job a couple
of weeks ago I wanted it to be huge yes
so it's gonna be two weeks from Friday
but instead it was just a two-hour
meeting with HR in the movies it would
have been this big steep hey everyone I
quit I would have been flipping my way
out of there parkour style finally make
a move on Julie and a mystery or poker
hookers always cooler in the movies in
real life it's just me explaining the
rules to a bunch of idiots cool so this
is a flush right know you've all read
cards you need all hearts for a fly yeah
red red red red you know it doesn't
matter how many red cards they have to
all be hurt no Yugi you can't what it
should be this scary high-stakes game
against some Russian arms dealer
Romanoff Lipinsky a cheat where I beat
him on the river and leave with his
money and his girlfriend tits dude I'm
so we got to live life harder if we're
looking at things
oh my god thank you guys aja yeah that
was like out of the movies or something
yeah wow thanks so we'll see you then if
Speth okay you get our number hit yeah
that's her only next time she gets Mike